veamos pues nuestra inclusión que
tenemos sobre el concepto del límite
primero vamos a dibujar unos un eje para
representar una función aquí estamos
dibujando el eje i
y ahorita dibujamos el eje x ahorita nos
vamos a concentrar sólo en el primer
cuadrante que es el más sencillo de
entender hasta que necesitemos de otros
dibujamos aquí una función en la que
está con morado una cosa suave
la función f x
y para entender mejor veamos una función
que no esté definida en un punto
realmente no necesitamos que nos
definieron a un punto pero es más
interesante y es mejor para la
comprensión pensar cuando no está
definida por qué porque en estos casos
el límite es cuando realmente puede ser
más sutil digamos que no está definida
en el punto c o sea no tiene valor
correspondiente en jay y así se dibuja
la forma de pensar sobre un límite es a
que se acerca de fx cuando el valor de x
se está acercando así por ejemplo
tomamos más o menos un valor cercano a c
entonces vemos en la gráfica a que se
está acercando f x
es el valor toma eje x tomamos otro
valor un segundo valor más cercano
todavía excede y vemos a qué se está
acercando vemos que se acerca a ese otro
punto en sobre ella
y ahora tomamos uno que realmente
realmente está muy cerca no hace y vemos
a donde se acerca en que podemos ver
podemos observar que realmente cuando x
se acerca mucho a ce podemos ver como la
función f se está acercando sobre las 10
a un valor a un valor fijo
digamos este valor que le vamos a llamar
el ok el valor que estaba remarcado con
una línea más fuerte
ahorita solo hemos visto cuando x se
acerca por el lado izquierdo ahora
tomemos como se está acercando fx a un
punto cuando nos acercamos hacia ce por
el lado derecho tomamos un punto y vemos
que se está proyectando en el ya es un
lugar luego tomamos otro un segundo
punto y vemos donde se acerca en el eje
y cuando realmente está muy cerca de
nuevo pero ahora por lado derecho vemos
que el punto se acerca
el otro punto no al mismo punto que
teníamos
a ese punto al que se aproxima tanto
como la izquierda como por la derecha al
mismo tiempo le llamamos el ok o límite
el límite la función
no siempre se llama l pero es una letra
cómoda porque nos da la intuición de que
estamos hablando de un límite
matemáticamente como escribiríamos esto
es que el límite de fx cuando x se
acerca a c es l
como está escrito en la ecuación
ahora es importante recordar que esto es
solo una intuición sobre los límites no
es realmente una definición matemática
rigurosa pero te da suficiente poder
para empezar a calcular límites y
empezar a utilizarlos en los próximos
vídeos vamos a ver una definición más
rigurosa matemáticamente con la cual
podremos demostrar realmente que el
límite tiene un valor